we have one application along with
reports on planning fields and planning
reports and service progress report for
section 106 legal agreement update and
the value of Illinois
just a reminder that at the last three
reports we'll be able to then try to so
that when we come to any Public's still
in the room will be asked Jimmy and the
live stream of the meeting
thank you
all right so wrong for this afternoon
uh yes chair we've received apologies
from councilor Hancock what we
substitutes about how to repeat with me
we've also received apologies from
counselor Liquors
[Music]
counselor Jones and councilor Hall thank
you chair
thank you anyone with any other
apologies
item two Declarations of Interest
when was I requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
jewelry interests and or other interests
not already on their register of
interests
in any maximum Weekender and we've
brought in the meeting at the
appropriate time if you really know this
highly interested Studio there nope
I'm a business leadership thank you
item for the application which is Ned
falls through 22 before 12 0 0 3 4 9 4
stroke FL at ethanol
the line of our normal practice I'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about any lame comments and to
give a free presentation shown any
photos and phones on the site
I will allow the officers to complete
the presentation consequently eventually
please reserve any points of order or
questions about the process until the
end
um
science shows the application site I
like to be uh the application site
before I use their garage side situated
to the United States
the red line meditation upon um I was
trying to decide this Access Fire and
interesting data access which is
situated Jason by the dental advantages
at these five and the 395
and so similar to the occupation side is
set back
possibility meters from the highway Edge
unless you can see from the left line
and find the proximity
please
this slide shows a cross-section of the
of those development stimulation to the
Jason Albertson Queensland High Street
in this case in the Puritan Island High
Street
that image is a good
stopwatch and
[Music]
um
similarly
um the cross-section here is sure of the
relationship with those property and
this relationship with Jason having so
you've identifier Sports by my street
this slide show that um tight lines from
has fallen in those days for elevations
within those growing from relationship
offices of reasons things initially the
separation distances between those
in QX celebrities
and this slideshow is the proposed for
this elevation those are near elevation
of running post growing and actually in
red as you can see is the super soothing
proposals for the garden so in effect
the primes of being a mandate and the um
the edge
of sort of essential imposed in terms of
the heights with those
excuse
um
elevations of the proposed line again
uh who wants to play with says it's just
one of the two of those at the site this
is looking at the size Square along with
my screens
um so the center of the photos with
vehicular access which ones between the
driving distance Running Springs and
high streets and the trees with an
application site Anderson towards the
end of the ground social traffic again
in the center of this Niche
um views of the specific site with the
coastline is somewhat obviously
properties that have on my streets that
makes sense
um the final photos in the application
sites itself working in the southwestern
Direction on the left-hand side of the
very so there's a garage building which
will be retained with the addition of a
new extreme protection shows the real
organizations of the product systems in
High Street 39 in the center of the
picture as you can see on the left hand
side of the image beyond the territory
exists in trees
um
beyond that
um summarize the conclusions of the main
funding considerations which are set
down in all of the Civic laws obviously
ability to be the subjective conditions
that proposal to representative
extensible issue of addition to the sun
over the satisfactory Community levels
currently ensured by the occupies
enablement practices in relation to the
mature sycamore trees or not removable
or taking abuse of the council's free
episodes
sort of the view that the terms will not
matter protection by rated free
installation either
and I remove and facilitate the
development composed is therefore
considered to be acceptable it's been
said that there are no other technical
reasons that would become through exhort
this recommendation of condition of
approval planning systems and that
includes the presentation and care I
just wanted to add a little relationship
by Nature on top of age 25 there are a
couple of measurements 10 meters and 25
meters are referred to the 14 sorry the
10 meter distance should actually be 14
meters I apologize for that chair that
does and make the the other measurements
either separation distance
arithmetically sense so I apologize for
that and of course it does doesn't
change the opposite view in terms of the
impact on the number 39 High Street
leaders and they started in absolute
number of times better inspiration
distance
thank you now do you believe we've got
two speakers this afternoon that are
going to ask about the proceedings now
so everyone is full away
yes thank you John
um I can say we have two speakers this
afternoon uh George Babel who is the
agent and Victoria Jones will be joined
us by Zulu
uh both of the speakers will have three
minutes to perform with their views
we're reminded given by the clock on 30
seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the streaming
questions if necessary
or clarify any points that they have
made
after the speakers addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting
but they will not be allowed to
participate further from this point
a debate by the committee on finding
determination on the application of fire
votes the votes will be taken by roll
call
family members this meeting is being
recorded and that will be placed on the
council's website
in order to assist those who are
watching on YouTube or joining via Zoom
they'll be helpful if members complete
now speak clearly and directly into the
microphones
and finally members please note that
will resume choose to copy this
recording thank you
thank you
you know first speakers
if you could confirm your name and I'll
let you understand your proceedings
foreign
accordingly there's even the subject was
substantial five-bedroom family room two
stories was through situated
at the new consideration of the
following objections from The Neighbors
regarding obviously requested that the
height of them you should do well at the
overall Florida for years
and that department
will ever knowing they've only
introduced the two stories and so did
you already produced from
3027 strategy to 2230
the roof line there's not much
possibility
the distance is about because you're
generally compliance with the
supplementary doctor the successfully
place of the guys doing practices
they read the scheme was better received
by the founding officer although the
previous subject system that's entirely
satisfied
it's actually showing the height and
distance relationship to the proposals
with number 35 last year with the armies
who lived in the show which is true
about it as well the general to assist
with streaming
foreign
I suggest that there is a
demonstratesability is at all times
closely with the planet of the city is
Page income this is to become a certain
Dominicans we're just therefore the
reciprocation is
thank you are there any questions
no thank you very much
speakers Victoria Jones
many years
hi my name is Victoria Jones I'm at 45
High Street
um
I think the property looks beautiful and
will fit in with the area and my main
concern is the distance measured from
our house to the proposed house
this is excluding our conservative
measured from the main building not the
consulate between the 21 meters our
conservatories our main living area We
Dine in there we eat in there we spend
our whole Christmas in there
um the house is above two two and a half
meters an inclination to our house which
therefore means the ground floor will be
looking directly into my children's
bedrooms and looking into our play area
in the garden
um
again also looking straight into our
Conservatory although these two trees
there at the moment that you saw from
the imagery six months of the year
there's no leaves on those trees and
therefore they're looking directly into
our house so the distance I'm suggesting
isn't measured correctly and the
inclination isn't taken into account
and my second point is I'd like to
ensure that the two trees at the end of
our garden aren't damaged when the
garage is taken down as the roots are
attached to the garages and these are
our only
support for privacy at the moment so
although
there are privacy they're going to be a
hindrance for daylight to the new
proposed property and therefore I'd like
to make sure that no damage is done to
them when it's been built also once
those garages are removed what's going
to be put into place that there's no
floods from the rainfall going into our
garden because we've seen this on the
High Street where there's problems where
there's excess fluid and then it falls
down onto the High Street and causes
problems with the um houses below
that's all
thank you are there any questions
no thank you very much
if there are any questions for you this
is
thank you
um
the width of the past okay sorry the
road or the accessories what I want to
width about this
Narrows for me
100 years it looks very narrow I don't
think the pictures
um
in terms of more General kind of safety
um
commercial highways or consists who are
where there's no objections developed by
a highway
and in addition to that
um
existing new service it goes side of the
traffic generates and meetings and
therefore
who organize the balance of the
application which is not really
certainly makes sense of all harm on
collaborative safety perspective
um as regards
specifically that could be something
that was sort of kind of age and
in terms of essentially a Judiciary
planets I've mentioned it um
but I think they were more advantage of
their story there with rather than
necessities
so I assume that the um the collection
will be taken from the highway itself I
think that's okay the two garages
available obviously vehicle access is
acceptable I just didn't know whether
that would take care of the binary and
ambulance require anything or anything
like that or whether or not you know the
necessity alerts in England
no to receive as it was just revised
chair we've not received any object from
the highways on that I've been
absolutely like horror of bay and yet
a car at least in and out there but it
may be yeah
it's not why it's just it is
my idea would be if there's nothing
there that wouldn't today or things to
be properly the access it made was
coming certainly would require that
we've been to present to the curbside
that baby requirement and certainly in
terms of that um accessible ambulance
and fired then we find a way
[Music]
images
and there are only conditions recommend
is
to preserve those trees or although the
detection zones but that might actually
be the numbers but he likes to consider
just in the initiative is probably the
slider back on the screen and hopefully
how it stands certainly it's those trees
that you can see on the left going on
rather than they are and outside the
application site and there's no need of
the ones that the student is referred to
the ones that's about to register
reports that wants to the right hand
side it was for you
let me tell you
any good questions
[Music]
yeah uh
on the channel we're also differencing
the height between the proposed
development
um the hours which are on the roadside
uh we saw two miles and sort of like
this one that what is the distance you
hide between your children
and the distance
um or the difference in time is to be
around two or two and a half meters
in the side of the General Social Works
towards the the proposed ways that's the
difference in height
um
according to the cross-section applies
that we provided
is that because uh the ground level is
promote are they on the same ground
the
application property
into the hillside
um but it's part of the existence
operators
position to for those properties
um political High streets
so if
what would be what should I say what's
the true height you can follow me uh on
the ground level of words come back to
the illness
but in effect we acknowledge that these
the proposed property would be
positioned in the elevates position and
the comparison to the properties
responses High streets and how I go in
this is because we've looked at the
separation distances involved between
that before and windows mysticism
based in the principality of the
post-procity and the Common Ground
series and we believe that this is in in
accord with successful devices
um by and large and various months and
our planning conditions because
one of those conditions within the
eldersfield places in fall
the windows servings back room number
four which is the closest habitable in
the window that's an elevated position
to see
um reports of fire Pine streets
yeah I could ask another question thank
you uh this is the question of the true
now
others look at the culture now
the maturing on the right-hand side uh
the second one now up the side region
you could see a lot more of it
uh you can see the boat that looked at
the show on Saturday June because this
one
basically doesn't show much about his
return but this is quite a substantial
truth
and I understand that the proposal is
development stream
uh and there are no ptos on it
now
we're being given uh new and everything
plants as many trees as possible
well that tree is about 14 50 years old
I lost the pipe planting all these are
called shrubs
the half of the Lord died and we think
there's a tree like that he just want to
do it degrees and development and I
cannot see the sense here and if we look
at the droids of the family and it shows
the tree uh as a circular okay to find
the original front which you saw at the
side of the news
and perhaps see what I mean
you know you could just see the thing
there was one there slapped back in the
middle uh and then there's one at the
back now
I look at it like this he moved the
building uh just to feel a couple of
Majors further back there will be no
need whatsoever took about but perfectly
health is true
uh and also the one they can't
tell me uh perhaps explain to me the
sense inferring the perfectly held
Victory
I think in this instance during the
proximity of the trees that impose
flooding officers would mean the tension
of the tree would perhaps preclude those
developments so we'll have to take a few
as suggested in my conclusions that we
saw the music announcers Trio was said
um and was taking it in based on that
and ultimately the view is the council
and or obviously wouldn't
um affordable protections of this
particular Tree by the way of a true
preservation for for a number of actors
one of which is it's immunity to
contribution which is diminished as a
consequence of it being set apart from
the highway that only really see the
eclipses on on High Street
um secondly the tree would be the trees
the remark for removable was
um
the audience elements at the rear of the
side of the law of an edge of the sign
so in terms of
um
like that would be retained uh despite
the removal of the tree and the further
consideration raised by the tree of the
source of the tree is a boundary which
does raise some potential issues
um in terms of whether it would marry a
protection But ultimately to conclude
the view of officers is that the
retention of the tree
would likely for clearing the proposed
development of the side with a single
environment of this nature
um and ultimately true would it be a
merit assuming preserved to to
um but there was a true preservation or
the sector in that manner
that's already very interesting but as
well as I'm concerned
it's a moral thing within the book
of the health insurance
could be saying that's just my opinion
gently used to do to what college said
in terms of the the H longer between
Scholars explained in taking a v1x
citation and its relationship to the
development and we don't believe that
the house we post form and the treatment
both be I'm currently but couldn't both
exist in our view and that's why we
complete Revolution is in this instance
of the reasons set down by Colin the
development from it retreating that
certainly this is going to go to the
men's T2 rmps because everything else
that's that's in balance that then also
have to consume a new one in terms of
maybe they're changing around as
volunteers refers to of course we've not
discussed that with the the applicant to
care so again that was an issue with all
members that you wished us to
investigate the applicant we wouldn't be
able to do that team with any insurance
foreign
that what are we saying you said that
it's detrimental to the building is it
or is proximity of is that the extension
number between the 14th and yellow and
you're putting the yard away and the
whole building either way is that insane
what what why have you come to the
conclusion do we can't be allarded or
crowned the cat as opposed to failing
that's all I'm trying to find out my
mind I I think now the volume of the
building has been reduced I think it's
fabulous and I have no issue with this
application I have an issue with the
trees
the the conclusion we've come to shares
because the application seeps okay
the expense of the team truly says
what's going to be determined and it's
the view that we're taking consultation
with the advice at the end from The
Young or a coaching officer the tree
itself isn't so it's amenity values as
great to Warrant the reviews for the
application at the expense of the tree
and so we come to the Judgment that in
this instance our users there is no
reason for the issue of the tree alone
to prevent the alarm at any place in my
view would be as it stands the the tree
is so close that the proposed learning
that it's aligned to
surviving the building worth on site
that would be my view however that
doesn't stop the committee you choose to
completion of the development is that
acceptable and the tree should be
retained and it takes his chances with
if it works for example
um
I'm
advised by colleagues normally on the
the issue of conditions and I don't
understand I don't believe there's a
reason why a condition couldn't be
required to sorry impose to require
attention of that tree but I couldn't
say to you that it's long-term Health
would be
would be guaranteed should you do it
that way around so you could impose a
condition
including within the Landscaping
condition to require laboratory
experience changed and it's the
enforceability that down the line
without affordable protection which
which just gives us the cause
but it it could be done I would wish to
guarantee the long term liability that
tree and post without becoming database
but thanks I do and that's where I'm at
you know it would give the two three a
chance I believe we should I believe
they do the a is a screening Mrs Jones
she's talking about and what but why
would you put it apparently help your
tree down if you can make it work if you
can go around and I I'm all for the
application
but I'm also keep in that tree or at
least give me each chance to survive
between
property was proposed and Mrs Jones
is still and explains the only GLT or
whatever
but we have to we have to phrase a
condition
um sharing in in accordance with
condition aid but it's made specific
records and understanding the submitting
plans of the foods on the side should be
retained in measures to protect them
during development defense
yeah we wouldn't normally um intend
putting a
protection order on a tree within the
counters only should that in this case
because we are deemed to be a
responsible over them so it will give us
the opportunities as well to frame the
condition that works and also look at
all the measures and positive protection
of it
motion chair
explains the situation
in the future
please go to my members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before the
votes
if an amendment to a motion is moved
exactly and that's Amendment would be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the opposite recommendations
then the member who has moved motion was
given the reasons for doing so
the reason for moving emotion against
opposite recommendations should comprise
the development planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or otherwise this
does not passed that doesn't mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision
through a further motion and favor the
recommendations of a different cause of
energy
this will need to be approved by the
community through another votes
in terms of the timings of the Motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee Was Heard Randy discussed
the evidence report
chairs now indicated that we've reach
that point and she has now asked for um
thank you
um I'm happy with the reduction in
volume of the building I'm happy with
the pitch on the garage for extra
screening
um
recommendation providing the right to
the recommendation about between trying
to keep the tree or give an
international
but it would be in the reading chair
that we would incorporate within
conditioning to require that and then
um following through some issue about
retention or implanting and which would
be conditioned now exception
thank you
[Music]
yes thank you
okay and they just asked one of the
questions and Catherine is just
referring to that that one tree the
larger Tree on the side of the building
thank you
so just to be clear that members it is
to approve office of recommendation
subject to changes of good conditions to
the fact the discussion today about the
trees in that area
okay in which case councilor Armitage
well
councilor Cooper or
and so hard so again
councilor Powell
councilor routes
oh
councilor growth well
and Council wait wait
um
the motion is passenger
thank you all very much thank you very
much
foreign
I think the planning manager may or may
not be commenting on this trip
with the technology care I apologize
for a second and the report there chair
in school members to to note
you may have been seen recently that all
members are now receiving the decisions
that we get on the fields and that's to
ensure that we keep up to date with any
changes that members
um uh that could be
the constitution of the council if you
like um through election or whatever and
we missed him recently that one of those
changes so all members are now receiving
decisions just in terms of the the paper
report I'm sure members will have seen
the two red mile recipients which
followed an informal hearing a couple of
months ago and members may recall the
discussion that took place in respect
for those applications that killer Marsh
and we may return to that debate and
shortly but that in particular is worth
noting and a partial order costs have
been awarded against the Thousand
respect our bonuses
on that in terms of the assist appeals
shared the one for Mr Gay at Milltown
made some interesting comments regarding
sustainability of development in
Countryside areas but did you have a
great deal of validation to the areas of
multiple environmental sensitivity which
are set out in the local Planet which
you'll see often referred to the
committee reports so we're very pleased
with that decision and we've limited to
give to some of your Environmental
Protection policies that we often
describe to committee Mr Roland and made
again a good decision in terms of the
council but that made some interesting
comments in respect of limited
development in the Greenbelt and the
community even limited engineering works
in the green belt and had a detrimental
impact so again well worth a read and
consideration of that issue again
validation of your strong Greenbelt
protection policies which again we often
discuss and debate into Community chair
so they're just some highlights from the
report of yours reported being it would
be another
few to be next to the next time around
but any questions
any questions
sometimes
you said as much as old urgency I have
none
as we move to items eight which is the
region of public
ly excluded from the meeting during the
discussions of the following items of
business to avoid the disclosure to them
of exempt information as defined in
paragraphs two three five
[Music]
is it content
okay
um the zoom feed will remain on as
that's okay Larson put the uh YouTube
sort of broadcast all ends I think
that's necessary of course that we've
got some presentations for two of the
year it's amazing okay thank you chair